Do you know microplastics?
Microplastics are observed not only in the sea...
...but also in the mountains and the atmosphere.
There are two types of microplastics.
One has been manufactured in micro size,...
...for instance, the scrub in microbeads...
...that are ingrained in toothpaste and detergent.
The other one is manufactured in large sizes such as PET bottles...
...that have been crushed and subdivided into micro sizes...
...in the natural environment under the influence of ultraviolet rays and collagens.
According to research, we consume one credit card worth of microplastics a week...
...through the air, food and so on.
Also, we discharge microplastics into the sea and rivers by washing synthetic fiberglasses.
What should we do now for a better Earth?